there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock tada here we are it's the
hundred and fiftieth episode yeah we're
gonna do something different we're gonna
do something different a little bit
kinder grab a variety of different
topics and we're just gonna let it roll
this might be a three or four hour show
I don't know depends on how you know I'm
gonna have three different kinds of
tequila three different types of tequila
we'll see how it goes they'll be all
right we'll see here's gang we got some
good topics but when I was first
conceiving that I didn't this is like
months ago because I am nothing if not
like I try to get on top of [ __ ] even
though I try to get on top of [ __ ] but
then by the time it actually rolls
around I'm like oh I'm not on top of
[ __ ] so you know but what I was
initially planning on doing for this
show like a very long time ago was I
thought we were gonna do one on location
and specifically I wanted to do want to
see an Augustine because there's like a
lot of like ghost stories and [ __ ] there
I was like oh that would be neat if we
could like go there and walk around st.
Augustine I to talk about a different
ghost or racially I'm kind of glad we
didn't do it because I might be out down
there for a couple of days yeah and I do
like you know broca's [ __ ] so you know
so that didn't work out and then for a
little while we talked about doing like
maybe a live stream and a couple of
people that is you mentioned being down
yeah that is really true it's seriously
if you don't live in Florida like this
is not like it even like when it's in
90s or hundreds or something like that
people like yeah top but whatever but
the other day they have a heat advisory
as in please do not go outside or you
will die it's rotten five degrees well
it was a hundred and four the heat index
is a hundred 1414 yeah yesterday or the
day before because of the humidity
it's like Dagobah yeah it's like and
it's not like desert it's like you go
outside and it's like you know how when
you like walk into a sauna like at the
gym
it's like that but everywhere and you
can't baby cookie baby cookie was out in
the living room trying to get my
attention look look look look look look
now look a damn snake in the house yeah
we got a footlong
Pookie's good though she always like
it's just like any other cockroach gets
in like gonna get a look and she'll come
and sit by it'll be like huh juicy dude
all the outside swamp all the outside
swamp creatures try to come in
hey even they're trying to get it up
like please save us air conditioning and
I felt really bad cuz I like snakes I
know a lot of people are scared of them
but I actually kind of like them and
this was just a baby
um I don't know again that ones need the
door yeah I don't know what kind of was
cuz I didn't see it but I kind of it's
like I almost feel bad like putting me
back it's like I wish she could stay in
here and hang out man I know it's gonna
kill that snake she would yeah I was
trying to grab it she she started to
swat when I grabbed it she started to
grab it she's like oh it's like yeah so
in the end like we might eventually do a
live stream and stuff even though we
didn't get our [ __ ] together this time
and like I said and in case you couldn't
tell like I still have this illness
whatever the hell this is which I'm kind
of hoping hasn't progressed into
pneumonia because it's just hung around
for so long it's dangerous to have me on
a live stream that's yeah see when I'm
drinking I don't know though because
like I said I and I was telling his for
he's like I don't know if that would be
such a good idea like especially our
drunken stuff cuz I might say something
you know [ __ ] yeah it's like although
I'm sitting there thinking well we do
the show live like we don't really play
in anything I got you guys cut out and
not much gets cut out on him and and on
and dropping things or something yeah
like if something like that happens or
if like some you know if some of the
ways happens and Outsiders like think
yeah the kiddie knocks over the camera
or something like that yeah I'll take
that out but other than that I don't
take much else so I said that you know I
wouldn't really worried that much about
it but so we will probably do one of
those in the future
but what we decided to do is this was
actually kind of Tom's idea I was like
well let's just do maybe an extra long
episode and he's like let's
do splick stuff base conspiracies or
like fun stuff about space so I was
sitting there because because I've been
wanting to do a show about like the
Apollo moon landing hoax I want to do
one about flat earthers and I also
wanted to do because I'd been I wrote an
article recently about the whole Black
Knight satellite type of thing so I said
well let's just I said those will be the
three main things but I think if you
want to go off on some other kind of
[ __ ] then you can do that too I got
stuffs come out about tick-tack UFO yeah
so you can talk about that as well
I just wanted to make something like not
so much like yeah I want to have like a
topic on here or like a series of topics
but I kind of wanted this to be more
like a fan yeah you know something more
geared toward fans that just like
listening to us yapping got all the
shirts that we need to do the shirts for
us for our subscribers on patreon man I
had to do a whole bunch of different
silks Chris different photo screens
Matt some of them I really screwed them
up but I got two of them that I think
will work it's the same photo yeah it's
just me and Jenny on it says 13 o'clock
so I'll print up another a print up
another prototype and see how it comes
out if not I don't like how it comes out
I'm trying to get it perfect people yeah
yeah there was a we had a couple that I
probably could have used but they just
I'm looking for perfection yeah you know
want something that I would wear you
know so I think I have to they're the
same image but I think out of these two
yeah one of them might be good enough we
just have to make um you know just have
just enough productions doesn't take
long yeah so we'll see which one comes
right and if this screen isn't any goods
back to drawing board I gonna get more
emulsion yeah clearly screen is so
difficult is the development time yeah
the exact because like all the videos we
saw like everyone uses different
emulsion like the motions are different
colors they're using different times and
yeah they have different setups it's
like you of them just put stuff out in
the Sun some of it put it in a closet
with a light bulb and it's like you know
without reflectors yeah with them
without reflectors so it's right
a bunch of different times in this dad
and it's really it's kind of sensitive
it's very sensitive so you have to kind
of get it almost exactly especially if
you're dealing with like a photographic
image with like fading and say that you
really want it faces you having the
problem with the faces
yeah the lettering comes out fine it's
just so it's the face of too much under
exposure yeah the problem is an
overexposure it's been underexposed and
I've been keeping it in there over the
over the prescribed time yeah it's still
under underexposed yeah even though I'm
using the light bulb in the darkroom and
you know that it recommends it's just
one time it was a little too dim if the
emulsion was too thick on one side and
that screwed some [ __ ] up
it's okay well then sometimes too if
you're trying to like when you're trying
to wash out the emulsion out of the
screen like sometimes if you if you wash
it too much like it'll start peeling on
like parts of it that you don't want it
peeled off and so you really have to
like be careful it's just my first
attempt at using photo screen and it
yeah I get good with it yeah takes time
all the screen printing you did before
was great a more traditional method
which brought out like yeah stuff like
that so this is our first time using
photo emulsion so we're just we're just
trying to get it right but you know
it'll be still get your first yeah just
don't worry about it yeah so um than
that I think the only other shout out
that I had before we kind of maybe start
talking about whatever was I wanted to
thank one of our patrons who was a
patron before and his name is Liam and
he actually increased his support in
this past week so thank you very much
for that that was super awesome yeah
thanks um so you know get a shirt no but
he'll be in no but he'll be in the next
drawing okay could be in the next
drawing which will be June July
September October I can't remember but
yeah so September October work we're
gonna be doing another drawing for it
it'll probably be more shirts because
we'll have all the screen printing stuff
yeah you know perfected by then so we're
gonna do like a different design like
every quarter so that's probably how
we're gonna do with that yeah alright so
let's get into talking about the Apollo
moon landing hoax yeah a lot of people
think that that didn't happen one well I
don't know if it's a lot of people up
here but some man guys
now you can go to the man so do you mean
any good I can't carry all the fuel and
I just said ma'am
never mind well you know it's it's like
one of those things that this is one of
those this wouldn't like one of the
granddaddy's of all like American
conspiracy theories right and it's one
that to me is just like the edifice of
stupid is just like so massive that it's
like you're not even really sure where
to begin scaling it you know it is this
like the Kilimanjaro or the Mount
Everest of stupid well I don't know if
I'd go that far maybe Flat Earth is is
that but you know it's this is the kind
of conspiracy theory where so much
evidence has to be denied or you know
sort of swept under the rug
that it's like why even bother going to
that length to you know I mean it was
there was a space race going on but well
I know that well I'm telling the
audience yeah all right there was a
space race going on between the United
States and the Soviet Union and there
are some people that believed that
instead of actually going to the moon we
were having trouble so we just faked the
moon landing in a in a what do you call
it not a theater a studio yeah they had
a special studio built to fake that
landing you know super get rusty effaced
and that they did launch a rocket but
they just did a couple horbet surround
the earth they orbited for a while and
they came back down to make it look like
they actually went to the moon all right
all right so a lot of problems with this
you know was him but Buzz Aldrin punched
a [ __ ] out oh he did yeah and
there was a video of it on YouTube I
don't know if it's there anymore because
the one link that I saw had broken so
maybe somebody took it down my father's
dad word for Grumman aerospace yeah and
he worked on this bridge yeah they were
one of the contractors yeah he's one of
the contracts and he drove one of the
they made several those lunar Rovers you
know what I mean he drove it on
mock up lunar surface and but what my
what my grandfather did was that he made
the explosive bolt wiring systems he
designed all that explosive bolts in
that in the stage separations he was
actually one of the chief guys me
he also engineered the fuel injection
system for the engine and the f-14
tomcat and he got sent to iran that when
we were on good terms with iran's with
the shah and he helped the shah set up
his air force so i have mentioned it on
the show so far but my mother's side of
the family all kind of grew up in iran
even though they were there were
americans and i got all kinds of stories
about iran they were living this behind
and all my aunts speak Farsi and [ __ ]
yeah but that and then they were there
for the revolution when the Ayatollah
Khomeini became my aunt Ruthy was the
last Western woman to leave off the roof
of that embassy yeah before they all got
you know overrun by the revolutionaries
you know she's you know the rest of my
like a pure they were held as hostages
in there until for Jimmy Carter's time
but yeah a lot of problems a lot of
problems with seeing that the moon
landing didn't happen but let's go ahead
and hear the theories what why do they
say that it didn't happen yeah the thing
is well there's a couple different
variations of this like you implied
earlier there are some people there like
we never even went into space at all
some people said yeah we went into space
but they only went into orbit they
didn't actually walk on the moon so that
part was faked you know I mean like they
launched a rocket with no people in it
but then like scooted the astronauts
over to Nevada or area 51 or wherever
the [ __ ] the studio was and filmed that
going on over there you know so there's
a couple different variations of this
and like I said there's a little bit of
overlap with Flat Earth Society too
because like flat earthers some of them
believe that you can't even go to space
at all
so there's a little bit of overlap here
to now really I don't know I don't know
if anyone down
the moon-landing until about 1976 and
kind of the granddaddy of the Apollo
moon landing hoax conspiracy was this
guy named bill casing and he wrote a
book called we never went to the moon
America's thirty billion dollar swindle
it was self-published a lot of stuff
back then was you wrote a bunch of other
books too but I think this was kind of
the one that had the most cultural
impact I guess but so from that I think
a lot of the conspiracy theory happened
so the interesting thing about it is
that I mean when people talk about the
moon landing they're talking about the
first one 1969 Apollo 11 but we've been
to the moon there were other Apollo
missions after that they all kept going
on yeah and they did the same thing each
time there were what six of them right
there yes at least six there was a
couple Apollo 13 you know there was an
explosion they messed up you know just
like the Tom Hanks movie and they had to
bring them back that the astronauts were
ok but they didn't get to the moon but
some of the other ones they did and they
did the same exact thing they put two
little astronauts on the moon and they
walked around and then one was in orbit
waiting for them and then they came back
so they have been six times it's not
just one time so I think there's like a
weird misconception there yeah well
they're not a one-time event yeah it
wasn't a one-time event it happened
several times it yeah there was that was
between 1969 and 1972 with Apollo 11
being the best-known and we just watched
in the theater
we've got documentary Apollo 11 is like
the 50th anniversary hey you guys I'm
had stars yeah it's like if you didn't
it's a shame if you didn't see it in
like IMAX we saw an IMAX whatever holy
crap that was amazing and like the
footage of it and stuff like that it
just made you feel like you were there
yeah and I think seeing that I mean not
only gave me a greater appreciation
because that you know the the moon
landing was three years before I was
born so I've only seen it I didn't see
it happen firsthand you know I only saw
it later on when I was growing up I did
but yeah but seeing that I was a baby in
a little I first and I think dude I
think I was a couple weeks old
yes and you remember an obsession I was
gonna say yeah baby's camera for
anything it's only about three years old
but um yes so but seeing that really
gave me a new appreciation and that was
kind of one of the reasons that I wanted
to do something about the a moon the
moon landing hoax just because seeing
that also made me a lot madder about the
moon landing hoax people because I'm
like look at all the people's memories
that you were [ __ ] on and all of the
people that you were calling liars or
shells I mean because it wasn't just the
astronauts it wasn't just NASA it was it
it was the contractors hundred thousand
people worked on this project in various
capacities and for all of those people
to be lying for some reason I'm like
that just seems the problem with the
hoax theory is the actual Saturn 5
rocket itself many of the many of them
were made and many of the boosters still
still survive today the big fat of
Saturn 5 booster rockets you can go
through those plans and you can execute
those plans today what you'll end up
with is a rocket that can get to the
moon it did go to the boom once you have
those plans and if you have that amount
of money it's easier to just go ahead
and go to the moon than it is to fake it
it's not really that hard to go to the
moon you can go with 60s technology well
and they did it yeah the really sad
thing about the whole Saturn project is
what happened with the Saturn rocket
they killed the Saturn rocket and
instead they made the damn Space Shuttle
yeah they had they just kept making
those Saturn 5 boosters those Saturn
rockets they were cheaper to make they
had a lot of them on order and you'd
have a lot more stuff up in orbit by
that by now that that space shuttle
didn't make sense
every time that rocket launched it had
to launch the shuttle and the payload
that's a lot of weight yeah you could
just get rid of the shuttle itself and
just launch the payload yeah no yeah and
that's that's what that Saturn 5 heavy
lift was all about have they kept going
with that Saturn 5 heavy lift desired
because it was designed to put a budget
bunch of stuff up in space and they just
kept with that then what you
in 2001 a Space Odyssey would have been
real yeah that's what they were planning
on doing you know including
nuclear-powered spacecraft and
everything but killing that Saturn 5
rocket was a big mistake yeah building
that Space Shuttle was a big was even
bigger mistake it should have just kept
it Saturn rocket you'd have a lot of
stuff up there right now
yeah prime it was a lot cheaper yeah I
mean yeah but like I said in this this
is kind of I probably mentioned this
before but this is kind of my beef with
a lot of conspiracy theories is that for
it to be true you would have to pause it
in this case that almost half a million
people were in on the deception and
somehow nobody said anything about it
figured it out nobody figured it out or
anything like that that's that's my like
I feel like there's an inverse
proportional it's like the bigger
purported conspiracy theory gets the
less likely it is to be jerko because
you just can't get that many people to
be quiet I'm sure that's a good enough
telescope to where you can just look at
the surface of the motor just see that
lander sitting there well that's the
thing it's like they've done when I said
my eyes of the moon like India did one
like some other countries have done them
where you can see like the tracks of the
Rovers you can see [ __ ] on there you
know what I mean like you can see where
the landing site was you know so you can
see it there there's also a kind of
thing and I saw this one guy talking he
was like you know on I don't think it
was the first mission but I'm one of the
subsequent missions they left like those
laser reflector things like on the moon
so it so you can bounce a laser off of
that right and get an exact reading out
and get an exact reading of how far away
it is cuz they put them there for that
reason right
but I mean there's also I kind of wanted
to go into there's a lot of good sites
about this but I found this really good
one on Phil Plait who is an astronomer
and I've read a lot of his book like duh
I think he wrote death from the skies
like about kind of comments and stuff
like that and he has a really good
breakdown of this one particular program
which I think it aired on Fox in 2001
and it was called a conspiracy theory
did we land
moon and he kind of did like a
point-by-point take down he said he took
like four pages of notes while he was
watching this stupid thing and he
couldn't like believe how deceptive it
was and like how stupid it was like it
how it didn't really go it is like it
didn't really have any skeptical you
know what I mean it's like all it had
was deniers on there they just had a
couple people trying to explain things
and then like try to edit them to make
them look dumb and stuff like that for
me the dead giveaway that we did go to
the moon all right was they had these
claims well when you're seeing them
walking on the surface it's just a
studio and they've kind of slowed it
down a little bit yeah I've heard that
real well they showed somebody reenact
that okay when they put on a spacesuit
they went on a fake lunar surface ran
around maybe they had some wires or
cables on them and then they played it
in slow motion it looks nothing like no
it doesn't look and they're dead and the
dead giveaways to sand the mess and yep
when those guys are stepping or kind of
running in the moon sand you can see
some of the sand go up it's a parabolic
arc you like an arc it doesn't cool
fountain oh yeah it doesn't prove
there's no air you're moving too slowly
yeah no it's falling in slow motion cuz
it's in it's in low G yeah and you just
can't fake that especially back in those
days you could think of a CG today yeah
but not that you distracted you couldn't
figure in the 1960s yeah that's just
stupid to even like posit that and like
I said I think a lot of the I think a
lot of the problem too is that people
since you since we here on earth you
don't experience a vacuum in your
everyday life so you're not used to
seeing how things react yeah so if it
looks funny to you in some ways that's
almost like proof of a conspiracy that
it's fake yeah even though you think
that that would be proof that it was
real because it's like well obviously
[ __ ] doesn't behave like that on earth
like I said Oh can't get off Pookie
she's like what I was yeah what are you
doing you're causing trouble like right
across yeah you just
hopefully it's didn't turn the [ __ ] off
yeah we're good yeah they're just kind
of they come all these weird theories
about you know explanations
well the reflections in the in the and
the astronauts is faceplates yeah you
know the shadows aren't right all this
kind of stuff no I've seen all that
debunked yeah and like I read yes and
like I said I'll go into this and I was
even watching I watched this really long
thing the other day about this they do
it's a company they do like 3d modeling
and stuff they do it for movies and
whatnot and they're trying to like show
how because that was one of the most
common things that they were trying to
debunk was that Oh a lot of these
pictures that you see they're supposedly
taking on the moon like the shadows of
the things are like not parallel as
you'd think that they would be or that
because the only light source is
supposed to be the Sun at least
according to them but then when this
company was trying to recreate the
images they said well the thing is yeah
the main light sources the Sun the data
flash cubes but they had well the flash
cubes but their spacesuits were bright
white the moon dust is really reflective
so [ __ ] was reflecting off of the ground
there was like all these different
reflective surfaces that were bouncing
light all over the place and honestly
the the way the shadows fall though it
does that on earth too there is more
than one light source like I said the
Sun is the main one but there were some
other like more minor ones but if you
had like pulled up really far like off
the moon and looked then they would have
been parallel they only didn't look
parallel because of the distortion of
the photographs and stuff like that yeah
so um but yeah so Phil played on Bad
Astronomy he did like this take down of
this particular this particular quote
unquote
I'm not even calling it it's it's a
mockumentary this is like a documentary
that was on the Fox channel in 2001
now they claimed that prior to this show
that maybe like less than 10% of people
and the United States or at least people
that were polled believed that the
Apollo moon landing was faked but after
this show it was more like 15 to 20
percent now I don't know if that's
really true or not or if they just
pulled that out their ass most of the
polls that I've seen Galla
poll Time magazine did a poll [ __ ] like
that it's usually about 6% which is
still too high because 6% is still a lot
of stupid people but you know that it's
better than 20% for sure yeah well it'll
all be resolved soon again I think for
the general public cuz we're gonna be
going back there eventually yeah I mean
think that you know well it's waste of
time I know it's a lot of good stuff on
the boat there's some kind of uh I think
it's called helium-3 or something or
what was the name there's some kind of
an element you can get there it's on
it's in this it's in that surface sand
or the surface dust of the Moon the Sun
hitting it creates it and you can
harvest that stuff and make a really
powerful fuel out of it yes this is
something really good you can power you
know you can make you can get fuel off
get off the surface of the Moon so
they're probably using this like a
jumping point to colonize other moons
well I mean I'm kind of the type of
person that I mean I feel like pretty
much any knowledge is gonna be useful if
it's not useful right now it might be
useful like down the line or it might
might be useful in some way you didn't
even imagine so that's kind of why if
you have a chance to like explore the
moon again if you haven't chance to
explore some other place we want to just
do it because it's like you know you
never know how well we have to call that
shits gonna like shake out later age is
that something there might be really
importantly we have to colonize all that
stuff yeah mankind's gonna survive you
you can't be a one planet species you
got to be a multi-planet species because
planets don't last long it's all finite
yeah you know something could happen you
could have a meteor impact here on earth
and just blot out the Sun for 10 years
you can kill everything here yeah that
happens you know mankind to be wiped out
but if you had a moon base or colony on
Mars you could come back later and
repopulate yeah it's like we're gonna
pop up to the moon for a few years we'll
be back when this is all sorted out but
yeah so one other thing you're gonna
make a moon I think they're gonna make a
Mars city eventually yeah I mean you
know they just send all the stuff there
beforehand and then people come and
assemble it you know we live right near
the SpaceX Center i watch those little
SpaceX Rockets take off and land all the
time yeah we don't live that far from
yeah you can watch it live on our TV see
we go 230 see them yeah and those new
SpaceX Rockets are reusable and stuff
like that you know with technology like
that you can start sending everything
you need to Mars you know to build a
colony yeah don't send people just send
the stuff well yeah yeah don't send
people and so you got everything out
there nice
nuclear reactors everything yeah I think
yeah well it's to where I could go on a
one-way trip I mean if they had
everything sorted out there I'm not
gonna go like in the Martian and be like
after this is saying and like grow
potatoes I think what they would do is
like for four or five years they did
nothing but just send everything
everything there yeah it would land and
then later on they start sending people
it wouldn't be like you see on the
movies one or two people they'd probably
send like two or three hundred well yeah
they'd all be getting there around the
same time yeah yeah you know you'd have
a whole breeding population yeah
then they assemble all the stuff that's
been dropped there and you got a city I
know he's gonna be cool there
underground stuff you know yeah be
boring at first till somebody opens some
[ __ ] up there well you sent 300
people all of them prettiest [ __ ] gonna
make a reality show everybody want to go
the real world yeah and you gotta gotta
be at in combined with Gattaca yeah now
one of the funniest things this cracked
me up so much about this [ __ ]
documentary you guys like one of the
first claims that they made out of the
gate and I don't know what exactly they
were trying to prove with this because
this is a very easy thing to look up
because we have a thing called Google
now yeah so the program says that oh
there's this movie called Capricorn one
I remember that which was about how NASA
faked a Mars expedition okay and they're
saying oh the footage you know that was
taken from the moon the Apollo moon
mission is really similar to the scenes
in Capricorn one yeah well Capricorn one
was made in 1978 which was almost 10
years after the Apollo
course the movie is gonna make it look
like the real thing because that's what
they wanted it to look like and they
also have something to go by
yeah they knew what a space mission
looked like that's what I mean so it's
like so any science fiction movie before
the moon landing well yeah it's like
hardly anybody got it right so the fact
that I mean why would you even put that
in your documentary you're trying to
show that the moon landing was a hoax
and going oh this movie from like 10
years later
looks like the footage that I'm like
well duh yeah it's like that was the
well that was kind of the whole thing to
why people are always saying like I was
Stanley Kubrick like helped fake the
moon landing and stuff like that because
Oh 2001 looked so much like a real thing
I'm like the reason it looked like a
real thing was because he went to NASA
and like had the engineers be
consultants on the movie cuz he wanted
it to look as realistic yeah well I
don't know that but if you look at all
the bonus features on the 2001 you'll
see that that was actually the movie
2001 was actually part of the damn space
effort it was they were using that movie
as basically kind of like an
advertisement for all their companies
and what it is that they could do and
the products that they wanted to sell
even those nuclear-powered spacecraft
like the discovery that it's all based
on the O's at the Orion spaceship which
is a nuclear-powered space ship it would
throw out three atomic bombs out the
back of it three per second they were
about the size of a coke can and big bet
in a big black blast plate on the back
and you could launch it from from Earth
and it was heavy it was like the size of
a small building a weight about what a
nuclear submarine would weigh big heavy
spaceship the heavier the better and it
would just put itself up on a dam wave
of burning burning nuclear plasma try to
get it up into space and when it was up
there that sucker could take off man get
to Mars in a few months with that with
that that rocket and they were gonna
make it but Kennedy cancelled it because
he saw that [ __ ] the Air Force wanted
some with nuclear guns on them and he
saw that he realized that the Russians
was [ __ ] and that they would that they
would build the same thing basically
building a Death Star yeah I put it in
orbit and you can try
like yeah let's build a different time
back yeah I think they should do it
today though they did the calculations
yeah it's gonna put some radiation in
the in the atmosphere but back in those
days they did that regularly with all
the nuclear testing and really it only
left as much radiation behind us a
couple of nuclear tests and damn you got
North Korea doing that now it'd be worth
it to get a good spaceship up in the
damn orbit yes me get that good make me
the captain I'm driving all right Thomas
volunteering radio this yeah on this
very show you backed into the engine is
basically a coca-cola bottling machine
colab Ottilie machine and it just throws
this dammit bombs out the bottom little
little bombs both sides of coke can
throw him out the back no technology at
all no computers they were gonna go
there we're gonna use that thing without
computers basically yeah yeah pointed
that way you're doing math well in a way
like that and seeing the Apollo 11 thing
just kind of like brought it home to be
like obviously I intellectually knew
this beforehand but it's like they
didn't really have computers as much in
1969 but it's like it was just all these
people and they had these big huge books
full of calculations and there's ladies
in there like writing all this [ __ ] down
anything like that I'm like dude that is
amazing amazing Mission Control was back
there when we think if you give her a
little bit thrust to their mom or inside
and they're in a space capsule looking
at her and I just take a grease pencil
make an X yeah that way no man has manly
[ __ ] well it's like a manly space I
loved I loved like all the shots of like
Mission Control it's like every single
like little little station had like a
big [ __ ] drink and a big all these
white dudes a flattop some glasses
yeah but yeah so you know I like that
but yeah what I was saying before about
Stanley Kubrick it's like I now correct
me if I'm wrong but I think the only
reason that poor Stanley Kubrick got
roped into this whole I faked the moon
landing the situation was one because of
how realistic 2001 looked which
obviously like I said is because he
recruited actual like astrophysicist in
the shining came out and just because
Danny had the sweater with the Apollo 11
thing on it that was only reason right
yeah I think that was only reason that
is what Kubrick was also like one of the
best directors you know he was not
beatable during that time yeah so if you
were gonna fake the moon landing that's
who you would hire do you know is that
someone made a video with a Stanley
Kubrick look-alike and claimed that he
had interviewed Stanley Kubrick and that
Stanley Kubrick on his deathbed admitted
that he had faked helped faked the moon
landing but it's like if you watched the
video well one the guy put the video out
and said oh I interviewed him on X date
or whatever and Stanley Kubrick was
already dead by then so obviously unless
he propped him up and like zombified him
or something and obviously the person in
the video looks a little bit like
Stanley Kubrick but not much how did
they explain all those command module I
don't really think they give it that
much though I I think that's problem
well like I said there's a lot of
problems but the problem with this just
like the problem with a lot of
conspiracy theories is that they came to
the conclusion first they think the
Apollo moon landing was faked for
whatever reason they want to think that
because oh I don't trust the government
I don't do this then the other so any
evidence that you show them to the
contrary they're going to explain it
away yeah so people with that kind of
mindset
I don't know how productive it is to
argue with them because anything you
show like they'll ask you it's like Oh
show me proof show me proof but you do
and then they're like oh that photo was
fake you're we're not that they killed
that person or they're lying or whatever
so it's like what what would convince
them what they're gonna say is yeah
those command modules are all sitting
there on the surface of the Moon but
they were placed there in the 90s by the
space show
yeah they snuck up there it snuck up
there and into the space shuttle put
them there to cover their tracks to
convince me well the thing about it
though is that even in their own like
delusional Minds because a lot of
conspiracies too it's like one and
particularly when I talk about the Flat
Earth thing it's like I don't understand
even if that was a conspiracy yeah the
earth is really flat in nightclub what
would be the full point of everyone
thinking that there's no point to it so
even though I can see that you know the
Apollo moon landing yeah maybe the u.s.
was like okay well we want to look like
we got to the moon before the Russians
okay fair enough that's not a great you
know [ __ ] motive but it's a motive at
least um but even if that were the case
if we didn't actually go to the moon the
Russians would have called us on that
[ __ ] because when we were like
broadcasting from the moon everyone on
earth could pick those transmissions up
including them in Russia now if the
people in brush it picked up the
transmissions that said they were coming
from the moon and dust said they were
come from like Utah some [ __ ] like that
they would splash that all over the
world it's like look at these
[ __ ] they're like you're gonna
fake it the wrong is they would have
told everybody yeah the world agreed
that those guys were wrong a moon yeah
everybody makes it like I said anybody
could have picked that transmission up
including the Russian I'm sure the
Russians were using you know
high-altitude radar to track to track
that capsule on its way on its way out
to the moon too cuz you know how curious
they were yeah that's what I mean you
see if their things don't cool if we had
faked that [ __ ] they would have known
immediately immediately and they would
have told everyone yeah
they'd be like if you point your radar
your radar you know trance transmitters
to this location we're supposed to be up
in space they're not there that's what
that's what they would say yeah but the
resin is what it does so another one
another um kind of argument and I used
that term very loosely but another
argument that they use is like oh well
how come in all these photos that they
took of the moon you can't say any stars
I mean you should be able to see stars
in these photos and stuff like that you
can though well here's the thing because
things happen I think with the way film
processes what I had well what they had
to do was because they were taking a
picture of the astronaut
you had like a bright white suit on and
it'll lands off well he had to have you
have to have like a really short
exposure time yeah because otherwise
it'll wash the photo out right so when
you have a really short exposure timing
the stars are kind of faint yeah you can
see the same thing happens on earth like
if you go outside at night and you take
a picture of somebody wearing like a
white person wearing like a white dress
or something like that like in the
foreground and you take a picture of
them and it's like a short aperture
you're like a small aperture like a
short exposure time then you won't see
any stars um on earth either even if you
can see them with your eyes just because
it won't pick it up is the same thing in
the desert if you're out in desert at
night with a bunch of cars you turn your
headlights on then you let them stand in
those headlights look back at those cars
and look alright you won't be able to
see stars yeah it's the same thing I
mean I'll just look black with no
headlights yeah which is exactly what it
looks like on the moon because they had
to use a short like I said if you and
I've seen like examples of this done
they said because you can even take some
of the pictures that they took on the
moon and you can take them in Photoshop
or your other like you know photo
manipulation software and you can
brighten them up to the point where you
can see the stars you can't see them but
when you brighten the photo to the point
where you can see the stars then
everything in the front just blows out
yeah it's like just a huge white blob of
nothing so that's why they didn't take
pictures like that and like I said it
happens on earth too so I guess they
don't know how photography works either
now another argument that a lot of these
people make is that is that when the
lander came down how come there was no
blast crater now this is stupid for a
couple of reasons
and I like that Phil Plait on his bat
astronomy blog said something like okay
lot of reasons every time you drive your
car and you pull into a parking space do
you pull in it at 100 miles an hour no
you do not the lander had a throttle on
it they throttle down they slowed down
and you would see that if you watch the
Apollo 11 documentary they were like
slowing down so in fact they were afraid
that they weren't gonna go quite slow
enough like to land on the but
eventually they just like got it in like
right under the wire
Lander wasn't really heavy either
there's no the module on top of it was
really just basically a glorified pup
tent really yeah it's real thin material
it didn't weigh a whole lot oh yeah they
made it look further either yeah it only
had a couple guys in it and then it was
in moon's gravity which made it even
lighter didn't require a whole lot of
power to you know slow it down yeah you
know you can see stuff you know dust and
sand being blown away a little bit yeah
but you know it's just you're not
talking about a whole lot of power
you're not laying there's only one point
five pounds per square inch yeah you
know you know you brought it down so no
crater it's a lot easier it's not like
they crashed into the surface well it's
not like they were landing on earth that
tail you know I mean Earth's gravity is
a lot more you know yeah and also in
zero gravity
the pressure like is dissipated well the
gravity they did ever well you know but
didn't give her like I think it's
one-third Earth's gravity I thought it
was a sixth maybe you want to say yeah I
think there's one thing but yeah it
spreads out much quicker than it would
on earth but like I said even if it
didn't they throttled down so much that
it wouldn't have left a crater anyway
now we talked a little bit about the
dust about how on earth that kind of
poops out like in clouds and stuff
because of air but it doesn't do that on
the moon and you can clearly see that
like when either when they were like you
know especially later when you see like
the little lunar Rovers like going
around and the dust like goes up under
their wheels and it goes like in a
little arc adjust goes up and comes back
down like it doesn't go poof like that
but that's why because it's a vacuum so
another one that kind of gets shown a
lot and I think I have a picture of this
that I took from some crazy whack job
site where they're like okay well the
the very famous picture of one of the
astronauts that has a reflection of the
other astronaut like taking his picture
they're like well why isn't you know
yeah he's taking his picture but why
isn't his hands up here like where it
would be if it was a camera I'm like
this is another thing that you could
have learned by googling the cameras
were attached to the front of their
spacesuits about right here
and that's where the dude's hands were
in the picture the thing is when you're
wearing a big [ __ ] space you need a
big [ __ ] space helmet
they're like obviously you couldn't just
have like a little [ __ ] camera like
that that you could just bring up and
like take a picture like you were in
front of the Eiffel Tower or something
like that they said they had to attach
it to the front of the spacesuit to make
it like easier to use and obviously they
practiced using it because they knew
that these were gonna be very important
photos and they couldn't [ __ ] them up so
they had to like practice you know what
I mean they had to practice on earth
with the camera where it was so they
would get it right and even then they
didn't get it right every time I don't
know if a lot of people know this
because like a lot of conspiracy theory
websites kind of say this is like oh all
the pictures look perfect and stuff like
that I'm like that's because they took
over 5,000 pictures on the moon and NASA
only shows the best ones like the ones
word that are all [ __ ] up or they
messed it up because they weren't paying
attention or whatever they just either
scratch those or they don't really like
publicize them because they didn't look
that good it's just like any
photographer worth their salt it's like
when you're taking pictures of a model
they take like thousands of pictures and
then they just pick a handful of the
best ones and like work with those
there's a lot of stuff from that mission
that you don't see yeah that documentary
that we saw that movie that we saw yeah
recommend is actually imagine you took
all the archival film footage stills and
all the audio recordings and you edit
that together into an action movie about
going to the moon yeah with with it with
a in it like an industrial soundtrack
that's what you'd get it's a badass
movie yeah I really liked it and I felt
like I went to the moon yeah it was huh
it was so much better than first man I
thought it's funny because I was just
like I was looking at another I don't
even remember what what site it was but
it was like a movie reviewing site and
they were like picking their top movies
so far this year and Apollo 11 was one
of them and they said and they talked
about how the same thing you said it's
like when you see this in the theater
it's like you were there it's like
you're going out cookies messing with it
if you would choose attack on the cam
she just to me you were just getting all
kind of trouble little baby she's
getting all she's attention get get go
play she's like I am playing yeah and
there was another similar one to like
another similar argument what about
where um you know oh when the lander
takes off from the moon to you know the
two astronauts that were there and they
had to go back up and get into orbit and
they said oh well when that you know
took off there was no flame coming out
so that again kind of proved it was fake
some do but they're like well there's no
oxygen no it's not you know it's not
because of that it's because the fuel
that they used in that particular it it
had a flame but it was transparent
doesn't it's a transparent flame it was
like a hydrogen hydrogen hydrogen rather
and diet diet
what if dinitrogen tetroxide yeah those
were the two chemicals to make a yellow
flame it doesn't make it yellow flame
the flame is transparent so that's why
that is also not evidence of fakery so
again there's just this whole [ __ ]
[ __ ] about and again once the one thing
that I saw and I just was reading this
earlier like before we started recording
this show is that they got like people
to be quiet about it I think even maybe
I don't know if it was this if this
particular documentary did this or if it
was some other site that did this but
one of them actually accused NASA of
killing a dude who was gonna come out
and say that the moon landing was faked
yeah even though he'd like died of an
accident or some heart attack or
something like that and it's like again
this it just kills me it's 400,000
people y'all 400,000 people at least
worked on the Apollo project did all of
those people live where all of those
people paid off nobody once just said
came forward and said oh I was there and
they
dinner blahblah it's like why why would
anyone do that and it's like now that
like I said the Soviets would have would
have told everybody at the time they've
they'd have ratted it out they had
motive to do that how do they faked it
it's like an even then like even
afterward when nobody had anything to
gain why would I think the first guys
that went to the moon that was the
second crew the first who got killed
yeah they can burned up in a fire in a
dam capsule okay
they've kind of got roped into the whole
conspiracy oh yeah yeah so they're gonna
kill three guys to get this conspiracy
going that's not it just to me it seems
much easier just easier to go to just
ago they were building those rockets
they built all that stuff that had it
yeah I mean so why wouldn't you just go
because that's at the end like I said
again this is the thing that bothers me
about conspiracy theories once they get
to a certain you know level it's just
easier to just do whatever it is you
said you were gonna do because when you
lie about something you have to keep
adding on to that you have to keep like
remembering like what person did I tell
this to and it's like you have to keep
like embellishing and adding details on
like as people discover the liar
discover like aspects of it so it was
like in the end it just seems like it
would be easier just to do it yeah yeah
so I just feel like once it gets to a
certain level it's just easier to just
do the thing instead of like lying about
doing the thing you know I mean it's
almost kind of like if you guys ever saw
the movie um catch me if you can which
is about that guy Frank Arbogast or
whatever his name is his true story
about a guy who was like a con artist
and he would go around he said he was a
doctor he said it was an airplane pilot
he said he was all this other kind of
stuff and at a certain point I'm sitting
there thinking to myself wouldn't it be
easier to just like actually become one
of those things instead of having to
like keep having to prop up these
elaborate fictions and worry that you're
gonna get caught it's just to me it
seems like too much trouble yeah like if
you're gonna go to the moon just go to
the moon it's like don't it's like oh
we're gonna pretend we went to the moon
we're gonna like say we're gonna have
this big studio it Stanley Kubrick is
gonna be involved and we're gonna have
to like kill 400,000
like no foul that we faked it and chill
like that it's just crazy it's craziness
and then there was the whole thing too
and I was gonna and I forgot to mention
this too but something else that a lot
of the conspiracy theorists bring up is
that oh well the whole Van Allen belt
thing where it's like oh well people
can't even go through that because like
the radiation and it'll kill you and all
this other kind of crap which it will if
you hung out in it but the astronauts
don't hang out at it they just like went
through and it only took like an hour
two hours something like that it's like
it was a negligible it's like you
probably get worse having a [ __ ]
x-ray at the hospital you know what
their radiation dose was gonna be yeah
exactly and they compensated and like
the metal of the spacecraft did actually
shield some shielding from solar
radiation also so now they were worried
about before they went because they
weren't entirely sure like the Russians
were worried about it before they went
but once they had kind of established
like how much of it was up there and
stuff they weren't really worried about
it like I said it would only hurt you if
you hung out in it like for hours and
days and stuff well they said that when
you're in space too you see momentary
flashes every now and then
yeah that's subatomic particles
penetrating you in the craft and going
through your eyeball and be pieces it's
a little flash of light in your eye yeah
but it's you know not enough to affect
your lifespan yeah exactly like I said
it was just like you probably get more
get in the [ __ ] x-ray and people do
that without even thinking about it but
yeah and so actually so it was when I
when I was scrolling down my notes I did
notice it was this particular
documentary that said the Apollo one
fire that the three astronauts got
killed in it was Roger Chaffee and white
and Gus Grissom got killed in the fire
um they kind of implied on this
documentary that NASA did that on
purpose
like because they were gonna talk to the
press about how that does that which
what the [ __ ] come on now
that's right that's ridiculous yeah like
I said I can see how I feel like a lot
of this stuff this kind of stuff like
the Apollo moon landing hoax like the
JFK conspiracy all that kind of stuff it
kind of happened after you know like
after the
60s in the 70s were and after it
happened after Watergate really because
there's like look you can't trust the
government look what the president was
doing so it's like I I get that like I
can see how we thought we could trust
the government we thought we could trust
three Finch you can't trust them
but that doesn't mean that everything
they say is a lie I mean you have to
have other evidence you know supporting
your argument you can't just pull out on
you but oh well the government said it
so it's a lie that's not necessarily the
case those dudes were hell-bent on going
to the moon they gave them money
they told him to do it they all wanted
to go that's what I mean it's like they
were are it system or dislike they
wanted to give a warning about they
weren't they didn't weren't the kind of
this wasn't the kind of situation where
they well you know this fake go into the
mud no those dudes wanted to go to the
moon yeah man there's a long history of
this [ __ ] go I'm all be back with the
explains and all kinds of weird stuff
you know yeah no no yeah that whole
scene was all about you know breaking
records yeah
air speed records they're trying to go
you know transonic and then they wanted
to go to outer space go to the moon I
mean you know this had been going along
for this had been going on for a long
long time with these test pilots and
this is just an outgrowth of that really
yeah it's now growth of kind of like
what was going on at the [ __ ] skunk
works and stuff so now these dudes were
all about it yeah and that's all about
and getting killed in an effort to break
the sound barrier or fly Mach 3 or to go
to the moon
no those dudes are ready for that
they're like honored to die well yeah
well it was seemed like a big it was a
big deal it was like a big human
endeavor it was something that had never
been done before and so you can see why
they wanted to be a part of this
monumental thing and I feel like you
know given that most of them had that
type of mindset they call me they the
right stuff and yeah it's all had the
right stuff no matter what their job
even if they wanted to beat the Russians
would there be any satisfaction in it if
they knew that they had just faked the
whole thing it's like it just seems like
a ludicrous ludicrous proposition that
like I said it was just like confounded
like the most this cat's drive between
paper fan of mode
you know no yes yeah it was a different
generation I think a lot of young people
today don't really understand I don't
think they're kind of people that would
really be willing to risk their life and
possibly die doing something like this
all I would do that
well I don't like I said I don't think
you can like it was these do [ __ ] on an
entire generation you know there's a lot
to be dis right guys are like that these
are these are thrill-seeking guys
there's always people like that in every
generation most of these guys came from
you know world war ii fighter pilots and
then test pilots these guys were you
know and and if they weren't that they
came from that scene their friends were
like that yeah as a whole scene and
that's what they did yeah and I feel
like like I said this I don't think the
moon landing hoax stuff I mean a lot of
like stupid [ __ ] that people believe
particularly creationism which is my big
that's like a big thing that pisses me
off but all this kind of stuff that
people believe most of the time I'm just
like whatever crazy person like it
doesn't bother me this one didn't really
bother me because I just thought it was
a bunch of idiots but then I think the
more I read about it and I think
particularly seeing like Apollo 11 and
seeing like a lot of that footage which
I had never seen before and stuff like
that and then when I started reading
about it for this show then I started to
get mad I get like maybe mad before but
now it kind of does because I'm like
you're impugning the memories of all
these fun individuals that worked on
this [ __ ] and like worked so hard and
got it to work and they were so happy
that it worked and you know the dudes
walked on the moon and everything and
everybody was all like yeah that was
awesome I don't get mad at it because
I've known guys that actually believed
this and they're the same kind of guys
that just love denying [ __ ]
so contrarian yeah they know that that
happens they just don't want to accept
it they know that it happened yeah they
just want to say that it did be what is
with what like what is with that what is
this psychologic I'm not a psychologist
so if anybody is what is this
psychological breakdown of an individual
like that because I don't have any a cop
I've known denialist I've known
contrarians does it make them feel
murder no they have like [ __ ] for
accomplishments yeah somebody else
accomplishes so they get mad I gotta go
that they have to say I didn't know that
didn't happen right to make very
insignificant or accomplishments or
their lack of accomplishments seem less
punitive against them you know done ma
right because they're like well I live
in my mom's beat yeah right yeah and eat
burritos Robin 11:00 I'm telling you
they nobody else has done anything yet
the [ __ ] either yeah they're lying so I
look like a little bit better bike back
it's playa hate there were a lot of
there were a lot of people are very and
in the late 18-hundreds early night that
when they saw Greek and Roman statues of
gladiators and gods they would say that
those were idealized staff that nobody
really did know gonna really look like
that but no there were bodybuilders that
came in the 1880 1800s you know like
Yugi Sandown some of the other ones that
looked at those proportions and when I
could do that and they worked out and
got this proportions yeah
and then people were like we're amazed
then maybe you know they had to go on
tour good oh my god that you can you
know huh Mike the perfect body yeah
that's gay porn was born they've had gay
porn for thousands of years yeah but
yeah but well I was reading something
about it um today I kind of went off
like while I was researching the show I
kind of went off to this big like rabbit
hole of like um you know like a lot of
like critical thinking literature and
stuff like that which I'm actually
really into I have like a ton of books
about on my bookshelf but one thing that
always struck me about people that
believe in particularly these big like
wide-ranging conspiracy theories I don't
necessarily think they're stupid
sometimes they're sometimes they're
ignorant of basic scientific facts or
things like that because I mean
obviously the whole thing about oh why
don't the stars show up in the
photographs if you knew anything about
photography you would know why or if you
know anything about optics so that's
like scientific ignorance but I feel
like they're not necessarily stupid I
think a lot of them are like of average
or even above average intelligence but
the problem is that there are so
insecure about the level of their
intelligence that they want to appear
more intelligent by feeling like they
know some kind of secret knowledge or
they've seen through the lie they took
the red pill you know what I mean
they've seen the matrix they know
everything isn't the way people told you
like so they want to feel like they're
part of this special elite that's like
not fooled by this you know what I mean
I feel like there's a little bit of that
going on like they want to feel special
or like smarter than everybody else I
think there's an aspect of that too
maybe but I do definitely feel like so I
so I would not necessarily call a lot of
these people stupid maybe some of them
have some mental illnesses when 80 some
of them are scientifically ignorant of
some types of things I think the guys
who were writing books about this just
thought that it would be a a book that
would sell well that's you there sure
like there's a whole thing where people
are just like bouncing a certain view
just because it's an alternate take that
might be that maybe might sell in the
market it might be sensation yeah but
they don't even necessarily believe it
themselves but they're just gonna write
stuff about them right which that
happens a lot like in law and politics
maybe the same thing well you know what
if I can get voters if I take it at this
angle you know let's go well yeah so in
that case you're just being a
provocateur right I'm talking about
people that actually believe like he
might actually believe that people that
I told you what my actual experience was
and knowing guys that didn't believe in
the moon landing they didn't believe in
the moon landing because they didn't
want to believe that the moon landing
well I feel like that's true yeah yeah
cuz that would mean that someone else
had greater accomplishments than theirs
that's really what it's about and you
speak and for whatever reason they they
come to the conclusion that well I don't
believe the moon landing happens so then
they just go and look for evidence that
supports that hapless is the opposite to
how science I'm supposed to work it's
like I'm just gonna look first I'm gonna
go look for some crazy person on YouTube
that has like some [ __ ] poorly lit
photographs it's like oh yeah but
they're not gonna look for anything
that's gonna falsify that hypothesis or
anything like that so I feel like
there's some of that
- I feel like they want to be like a
little bit in the special elite like so
they can like look down on other people
again smarter than you like I I didn't
fall for the lie that nASA has been
telling us if they actually went to the
moon for would've why would if they lied
everybody about it for 50 [ __ ] years
oh no no no I feel like there's some of
that going on - all right so we're gonna
take a little bit of a break when we
come back we'll talk about some more
space conspiracies Flat Earth type stuff
Black Knight satellite all that kind of
stuff at Earth isn't as dumb as you
think is this house yeah I'm gonna get
into it it's dumb it's dumber than I
thought when it appears to be okay
laundry comes like why you laughing